después de dos años de pandemia vuelve
el carnaval en el sambódromo de río de
janeiro un carnaval fuera de época en
abril en un ferrero nacional llamado
tiradentes que recuerda a un héroe
nacional que ayudó a liberar un estado
llamado minas gerais vuelve un carnaval
largo que va a durar casi dos semanas
porque vamos a tener durante cuatro días
desfiles los primeros dos días del grupo
de oro en la escuela de acceso que
disputan a una plaza en el grupo
especial viernes y sábado las escuelas
más querida las 12 esker y niñas de oro
que van a disputar el título de campeona
después la semana que viene el martes
tendremos la votación y finalmente el
sábado el desfile de las campeonas en
decir la escuela que gana y además las 5
que recibieron las mejores notas es un
carnaval único y la historia de río de
janeiro no se recuerda otra vez en que
río de janeiro tuvo dos carnavales
porque
que en febrero las comparsas salieron a
la calle a pesar de la prohibición del
ayuntamiento porque la ola de comida
estaba remitiendo gracias a una
vacunación récord recordamos que el 85%
de la población en brasil está
totalmente vacunado